father one thing I have not been doing
now I'm gonna do every episode from now
I need to remember is speaking of
subscribers and downloads and all that's
done you man subscribe mmm you know
what's funny
no one subscribes anymore yeah including
myself yeah so if you go on YouTube I
watch there's a certain few shows that I
watch you but I don't subscribe to any
you just type it in I miss and now
because YouTube knows I like it and I
don't even need to subscribe to just
suggest it on my share so every time
there's a new episode that pops up it's
all I don't need to subscribe it's
already there mmm
so normal subscribes no one likes normal
comments which is which would normally
be fine yeah but guys we need to know
obviously what you want mm yeah what you
enjoy what you don't enjoy and we want
to keep doing this forever so yeah help
us out give us a like give us a
subscribe follow us on Spotify our Apple
podcasts or [ __ ] whatever you listen
to us on and yeah man so we can keep
producing the car every social media
possible
yeah man gives us on Instagram Twitter
whatever man want every Facebook find us
like a subscribe follow whatever you
want to do man comment [ __ ] slag us
off if you wanna I care just be active i
honest let us know man because yeah like
I said we want to keep doing it we enjoy
doing it and it's a [ __ ] that you want
us to talk about and let me know but
speaking of why I want to talk about two
things first one is a rant yeah one is
just a gobsmacked up so the first rant
yeah rough mean vegans are gonna fall
out
me and vegans are gonna fall yeah hit me
bruv
so context one there's so much I can go
off and get me angry yeah thinking about
it so first off yeah there's a few
people if you're vegan right so
basically yeah if you're vegan and the
world knows you're vegan so let's say
I'm vegan hmm I put on Instagram I'm
vegan yeah
I post a couple things vegan meal
whatever I do my typical vegan warrior
[ __ ] yeah I post vegan this weekend here
from six months down the line I don't
need to tell you man mmm damn eating
vegan brownies yeah I'm eating a vegan
burger that me and vegan this I'm vegan
yeah so all my [ __ ] is very good don't
tell me that is vegan
you're even imagine if I started take
imagine if I started taking a picture
now just me yeah I'm an omnivore imagine
if I start taking picture of and just
caption glass of water mmm steak I can
see it's a stain yeah
chips not mean that like not even I love
these chips cuz their context no context
chips burger yeah
ribs Oreo milkshake like people will
cost me about why are you doing if you
put the word vegan in so that's the
first part more me hmm there's one
person that does it I hope she's [ __ ]
listening because I've cussed her out on
here so many times about it pisses me
off
who I don't want to blast her okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah he sees me yeah we got
back and forth I love her but yeah
stop yeah I don't think she does listen
she's too proud but [ __ ] stop EQ out
his [ __ ] stuff you know who you was
[ __ ] stop second point so with the
vegan thing mmm if anyone well I'm sure
some people that listen on a vegan if
you want to add your two cents please do
because like I said this is a rant this
is my personal opinion but there's
certain things that don't sit right with
me so with the vegan right I don't
really care what anyone decides to do
with their eating habits
you don't need to justify to me why you
want to eat the way you do if you want
to be vegan nuts wagon me vegan if you
have no reason why you want to be vegan
as long as you own it mmm that's fine if
you just say I'm vegan from now as long
as it's white and say because it's my
body not any gives you I just want to do
it then that's cool there are certain
things that like really [ __ ] piss me
off mm-hmm so one is where people will
say they're doing it for the health
benefits and they haven't really like
because you know there's obviously
there's a documentary to come out or the
movie that comment the game changes have
you seen it no I'm not seeing above
scene people won't shut up the [ __ ] up
people unsubstantiated evidence but
people will never look Internet himself
you know watch the movie and go off.that
see an ex UFC fighter say this is the
thing and they black that's fat
that's gospel yeah so now I'm gonna go
vegan and I'm gonna preach why people
and why meat isn't bad but they don't
know any facts they just listening to
what my mind said on the movie and
regurgitating it someone else yeah and
this is their new way of life yeah
annoying to that this is probably
somewhat the more annoying one so
obviously a lot of people will become
vegan based on the the moral aspect of
it yeah so they don't want cruelty to
animals they don't like the way animals
are treated in captivity and hormones
and the factory farming bro factory from
is disgusting I um that's fine
mmm but there's one thing that's
happening at the minute that is driving
me nuts right well so have you seen like
so like KFC and I bugging yourself
they're doing like vegan burgers a big
man
there's a guy in America I think it's in
America he is suing Burger King mmm
because they cooked he is because he's a
morality vegan if you can't think of a
better word but he's a vegan for moral
reasons when he doesn't like Cruelty to
Animals and stuff like that yeah and
he's suing Burger King because they
cooked his vegan burger on the same
grill and that they cooked the beef now
in hindsight you might look at that and
think ah fair enough man I understand
where you're coming from
you don't want the cruelty to animals
touching the same food that you're
trying yeah big man if that's how you
feel hmm and you don't like Cruelty to
Animals why are you giving your money to
a company that kills millions of animals
every year they make their living off
killing off killing cows and chickens
why are you going in there to get a
vegan man to get a vegan meal and you're
moaning there got cooked on the same
thing but you're so happy to give the
company money KFC if you go into KFC and
you're a vegan and you're a vegan
because you hate goats eat animals
you're gonna give KFC money so that they
can kill more animals but it's November
I'm Melanie food it's driving me crazy
it's driving me quit for weeks
I needed a platform about that is
bonkers and it all came to a head like I
fought that in it when I seen the
posters and stuff I think in why would
anyone go I think you first my first
always why I can't see making a vegan
burger because shorty if anyone has
cruelty that animals they ain't gonna go
kacy but I heard about the guy die soon
Burger King for the quilting and I was
like people have lost their minds yeah
people have lost their mind yeah why is
he giving them money in a know what's
wrong what's wrong dude up anything
there's no morality - yeah yeah just
you're just chatting [ __ ] for the sake
of here like you think yeah you have
this false sense of morality you you
genuinely don't know what you're talking
about like you don't know what your
response is shut up like I was [ __ ]
angry yeah I was angry so there was that
and then on the flip side of it as well
if you do it so if you're doing it
veganism for morality reasons why you
support in the animal killing franchises
if you're doing veganism for health
reasons why you in KFC bacon burger in
the first in the first deep fried of
course and it's chips so it's a
lose-lose regardless why let's get me
angry it's getting me angry fur that's
all I wanted to say I sincerely someone
comment
I hope someone comments yeah and so it's
like just give me anything if you agree
me if you just give me anything
something to play I'm ready house it's
been driving me [ __ ] nuts
that's a good point over but yet bravas
me Massey's that's a great point it's
been pissing me off growth it don't make
no [ __ ] I've never actually thought
about the fact that you're actually
going into a heavy cooperation that
kills animals day-to-day basis making
things kill more animals in any one then
anyone and you're in here like oh cool
yeah I hate 42 animals let me buy the
vegan burger I'll give you money to fund
your farm your killing spree so you can
yes um funding your killing spree it
doesn't make sense it stresses me out
it's that's [ __ ] out as well to me it
stresses me out brough I'm so happy
that's off my chest you know that's
[ __ ] well to me though because if you
had never said that I would never
thought that and I feel like that's how
people pitch ideas to companies do you
know I mean yes it is who the [ __ ] would
even think of that
you just see a vegan burger and you
think [ __ ] I've always want to try KFC
even I don't want to eat chicken but
[ __ ] there's a similar prototype that
what might taste good so I'm gonna try
it
you're still funding the same company
man to me it's different they're just
putting on a different hat it's the same
thing [ __ ] ya know for where that way so
yo you guys cuz you've got no leg to
stand on so I'll call your mum's oh my
days but the second thing I'll talk
about this is actually deeper juicy
sorry I watched this film the other day
called boy erased have you seen it is on
nay no I think I watched it on now TV or
sky cinema wherever his Lord let me give
you the premise of this movie mmm fam
let me tighten my brows sip it sip it
deep and slow
oh my god bro so boy erased premise yeah
it's basically about it's a true story
okay it's basically about this American
kid who's the son of a pastor okay and
he's gay okay and he's scared to come
out to his dad and stuff like that for
the religious reasons but he is actually
a child of God as well he's like
genuinely religious yeah so he's in
conflict with his own self about being
gay he doesn't know how he feels about
being gay and stuff like that and he's
kind of tried to figure out is he
definitely gay or anything like that and
it kind of just and basically they send
him to like gay camp I pray the gay away
that you go to a religious camp and they
try and convert you because they're like
making out like being gay as a choice
and all this stuff it's a true story
so is this at the point where he's
exposed himself to someone so he's
basically yeah so basically it starts
off him just living his normal life it
shows him kind of like breaking up with
his girlfriend he doesn't tell her that
he's gay yeah but he breaks up with his
girlfriend he's going off to college
yeah
seen a couple like in it they basically
starts off at him in the gay camp and
they forced the the people there to kind
of relive all the gay scenarios that
they've had and he goes into one of them
and so basically is him going off to
college and so he's there and I don't
know why I got invested I've got a
vested so quick I tend to when it's like
a true story
I love Vista so quick so he's he's at
college this is before I get sent off to
gay camp who ever he hasn't come out to
anyone in college Chilean first day
college he meets this guy mmm his name
was like I can't remember seems like
Daniel or something and he meets this
guy and the guy he meets is such a
typical like handsome gay guy mm-hmm
that you like is he gay is he not but
like he's a design some dude yeah so now
that we know that the main characters
gay anyway were like he fancies him mmm
I'm invested so you like oh cool
I can see the attraction kind of thing
and they start hanging out with boys and
they go to church together so neither of
them want to come out and say I'm gay to
each other but you can tell there's like
a connect everything here so there and
the main guy he's not done anything gay
before he's never kissed the guy he's
never like acted on his homosexuality
whatsoever okay so basically my man is
Chilean with his boy they needed with
him know that they're gay but obviously
there's like I said this chemistry and
they're just chilling playing like
called you or something in his dorm his
dorm and his roommates away in the the
main character storm and then he's like
ah do you want to ease like the bredrin
the handsome guy he's I getting sleeping
[ __ ] it's like whatever time in the
morning I'm his are my roommates away
for the weekend do you just wanna sleep
in his bed
you look tired kinda thing he was like
yeah yeah so he goes to bed mmm then the
main character goes to bed and he's a
bunk bed so he can hear the handsome guy
like Daniel whatever like tossing and
turning
these are Daniel you're right doesn't
answer him it was all right cool he can
hear him sometimes I be minding you okay
and then my mind comes down mmm just the
ladder he's like are you okay what's
going on he's like yeah yeah I'm fine
I'm fine I'm fine
and then like he sits on the bed and
they like alright cool like something's
cook yeah I'm imagining it I'm intrigued
no I mean treats again and because I
know he's never done any year he's never
acted on Johnny the Tet the the sexual
tension in the air and I was like oh
[ __ ] yes I know something's gonna happen
neither of them have explained that
they're gay yeah so like it's risky yeah
because you can't just lean in on man
you never know you never know
rock rock that's the thing but you can't
just lean in on that and they both go
church yeah you know they're both like
if he's not gay he's against being gay
yeah so like it's simple as that so
their bare clothes yeah but none was
acting UN distension thumb yeah there's
tension yeah so I'm like oh [ __ ] and I'm
thinking come on go for it go yeah I'm
scared for him to go for it and I'm like
come on go for it go for it um I think
he's named Jared the main characters go
Jared
gopher Gover and he's such a like a shy
reclusive guy and you like come on ruff
come on and then the main guy Daniel
goes for it in it mm-hmm and just kisses
him it's not like a lips you just go and
then like Jared backs off mmm
then comes forward a little bit and you
like now it's a party yeah so they start
lips in lips and lips in and this is
obviously Jared's first experience kind
of thing kissing kissing kissing and
everything's going well gone well then
Daniel slips his hand down gives my man
dick a little grab mmm so it's a bit
like yeah yeah yeah but obviously again
Jared's like a god-fearing man it's his
first time he doesn't know how he feels
about his own homosexuality so he's like
okay but he's not really doing anything
is a bit he's now resorts to stiffen up
a little bit and then my mind starts
like bashing him off kissing him there
my mind starts pulling his home piece
out
mmm and Gerald's like okay slow down
mmm they're my - thoughts angle him
behind him now pulling his boxers down
his [ __ ] now Jared's like okay slow down
so he's like slow down slow down yeah
then Daniel puts his hand over his mouth
and he's like Shh and the man's like
okay slow down slow down slow down firm
he rapes the [ __ ] out of him Daniel
rapes the [ __ ] out Jared know them he
grips his his mouth Yanks the shorts
down and shoves it in Jared screaming
spike [ __ ] screaming and he's banging
him and he's like trying to get him off
and he's shaking and he's trying to get
I was in torment I was not expecting
them oh my god the movie I was like no
the fear in me yeah the fear in me is
real rape
[ __ ] gangs him like [ __ ] bangs him
and he's like screaming get the [ __ ] off
me yeah and he shoving his face over so
no one can hear and all that happens is
that one of the girls like like shut the
[ __ ] up it's like 2:00 a.m. and then
walks off man screaming Daniel nuts in
him
then gets off it was the most realistic
portrayal of rape I've ever seen
I don't know it sounds how do I say it
sounds rude or ignorant or something
like that but obviously how do I explain
it when you hear about women getting
raped as horrifying and bad it is it is
it's more of a kind of conventional
scenario you know I'm saying like it's
hard for and because I'm not a woman I
can't really relate I can say like
that's [ __ ] awful like I don't I
don't even know what it's like for a
woman to have sex yes what hell if I
know boys I for one to get records yeah
I don't know how bad it's bad but like I
can't remember no defeat I'll never know
yeah hopefully I'll never know was that
to be resident I found when I watched
that you resonate he's there I was Jared
I was Jared I was howling I wasn't no no
I want to turn this thing up I was
terrified I was [ __ ] terrified fam oh
my no just like this is real life yeah
this is real this is real [ __ ] she
says plase a little story yes oh my god
it actually happened oh my god it
actually happened and then he had to
then this is all before with the gay
count but basically he raped him they go
about their business in it and my mom
stops fight like Jared stops [ __ ]
with Daniel now yeah they're not boys
and obviously just raped me cuz yeah
like we're not boys so on campus he's
duck in a diver man in there so now
Jarrod's getting shook thinking he's
gonna tell on me he's gonna tell man I
raped him so my man Jerad goes home for
the weekend Jared's mom gets a call
nunim was cool saying oh i'm the i'm a
counselor from the university i just
want to let you know that your son's gay
he's come out to me he told me he's gay
and I thought you guys should know and
then obviously the moms like what the
[ __ ] are you saying to me and like
obviously do these now being gay is not
a ting you can't be gay so she chats to
Jarrod like worldwide the dad is livid
obviously and
he's live from flyways he says oh my I
was like who was on the front I didn't
give you the name etcetera cetera cetera
cetera cetera and then he's like he
never gave me a name he just said you're
gay like is it true is it true is it
true and you say it's not true it's not
true okay and then he was like here's I
said why would he say that why would he
do this why would he why would this
person run an incall and then he's like
because he's a [ __ ] rapist like he
doesn't be he doesn't say he waked him
he just said his name's Daniel he told
me in confidence that he's raped people
before and he thinks I'm going to tell
you because I haven't spoken to him
since he feels like I tell him that's
why he's making up these last ten I'm
gay and it found the whole thing spirals
and then my man like can't keep it in
anymore
and then they're talking about the
Daniel thing like you know what his
dad's like now [ __ ] this give me his
last name we're gonna find out that
we're gonna get the police involved and
stuff like that and then he's like dad I
think it's true as well though he's like
what you mean he's like I think I'm
[ __ ] gay like I think I'm gay I think
about men I don't know what to do brav
the whole film I'm just like oh my god
oh my god because it's like in this day
and age especially like at this time
that we're at right now
being gay is calm it's like being
straight yeah yeah been straight being
gay is being straight now and that's
obviously not true I'm just saying that
yeah it's but it's just in comparison to
what it used to be is so much better
yeah I can only assume um so like to
picture what he was actually going
through I was just like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah that's dark yeah like I could only
save like from my perspective if my son
comes to me when it's older I don't even
want my man to have to feel like he has
to come out the whole concept of coming
out annoys me yeah why should you have
to come out like your heart you are
lucky so a big deal like it's minor
I'll be vexing my man said like dad I'm
ready to I start to tell you can you sit
down like I'm gay why you sitting me
down to tell me you're gay like you're
gay you're gay yeah like wait why do you
feel like that's unfit to sit me down
here and tell me about why yeah I'm like
I'm lucky it's gonna affect me in any
which way by
so if I'm to see his dad's reaction his
dad was having none of it obviously
because he sent into gay camp and the
things that they're doing in gay camp
firma to make you like get rid of your
gayness in stuff like that broth I was
like this can't be real
mmm this can't be real and at the end it
shows like the statistics of like how
many people got sent to gay camp how
many people commit suicide from being a
gay camp of stuff like that it was mad
comedy some was mad from the whole film
the rape scene oh my god oh my god I
just remembered I remembered I did like
when I was watching I think I can't get
raped yeah I can't get raped abused
burger at this before we have get we
have so I can't get right ice on your
ribs okay
I can't but you really episode three
away over you said you'd rather get
penetrated than [ __ ] get act treated
as a boyfriend you said to get a
predator a four [ __ ] five minutes and
get nothing after watching this film I
think I might have to take the
girlfriend thing I'm not joking
the way my man covered his mouth and the
way Jared or screaming nah nah the way
Jared was howling up I don't think I
could do it I think we're gonna have to
formally change my statement treat me
like a woman kissing me tickle me
wherever I don't think of you like Oh
lick my [ __ ] do what you need to do
like I'll suck you off whatever fam
don't [ __ ] me don't bend me over and
[ __ ] me please Jesus Christ
brav ah it was mind-blowing
mmm but then he got me and then like me
being me getting in like my head and I
was thinking this is like a is a good
one nothing to ask you as well like if
this is to Christmas if you were gay
yeah because obviously you can see
nowadays like if you walk around mmm you
can you can tell if you there's a
handsome guy yeah of course you
appreciate and then you can also see
like very effeminate guys mm-hmm and
have like a lot of feminine
yeah if you were gay yeah we told you
Mon yeah we do you think you'll be
attracted to like very effeminate guys
and they look more female or like
handsome [ __ ] guys probably handsome
you think you attracted some guys
because I appreciate handsome men now if
a guy's handsome I'd be like right this
guy's it gets [ __ ] that's what I think
that's yeah [ __ ] handsome guy gets
[ __ ] so yeah it'll probably be that one
Fair Play
how about yourself I think may probably
the effeminate guys why because there's
something I don't know there's something
about looking at like if I when I look
at a handsome guy like I said I think
right I got it gets [ __ ] which means
like I see him as like an alpha male fuh
okay so if I'm attracted to the alpha
male I'm the beta you had a bear you'll
get [ __ ] you him [ __ ] that's what's
happening oh man he's also ready to try
and flip the scripts and now I'm getting
bummed wastes man race man say no more
continue your [ __ ] story
nah but yeah that's my opinion yeah
obviously you guys can figure out your
positions but now that's the way I saw
it and then I was thinking like I think
I'd really like to have a gay son okay
and I was like I imagine I always have
these stupid daydreams just like I said
with the burglary things before I was
off these dumb daydream so I was sitting
there imagine I was like imagine if I
had like a handsomest [ __ ] son like
man's man son and now we just sitting at
breakfast and then man's chatting to me
about cuz like I said I don't want
people to be coming out to me yeah if
you're gay you're gay yeah um just
chilling with me but he's chatting about
[ __ ] guys as I would chat bar
fangirls yeah so I'm like like just raw
plating like a morning song or one is
are cool they'll be saying on my game
and what time to come in I'm eyes are to
free no you're doing another day in it
you gotta hear my yeah one slim thick
mmm
you be come as out beat beat I beat beat
dad and I'm not swear down slim thick
slim thick lips hmm suck me off in a
night deep alright gang gang that's my
dream I don't know why but that is my
dream that's funny
I just want men to chat to me not like
normal yeah yeah alright that I do I
just found in my head I was just smiling
yeah I'll just smile into myself black
that would be so sick yeah like I don't
need to ask guy go whatever man it man
sigh slim thick that's funny
fat lips juicy ass that's funny
nah my mmm beat sounds good once I'm not
night there's natural conversation and
actually you talk about everything
that's what I live for man none is
coming out child I never come out to me
for I'm fans off the back of light
talking about this topic at the moment
so this is off untouchable after night
same time off topic rather so obviously
I post a lot of gym [ __ ] I went am in a
gym I post like pictures on my cell
phone register then put on my actual
page where I put my story so there's
this particular person he's gay that
always like comments and [ __ ] on the
shed I post which doesn't offend me or
anything but I just don't entertain it
dude I mean I just leave it there it is
why yeah yeah but then it made me
realize how it makes girls feel when
guys do it because all right this is
just one gay guy at that comments on
probably like one out of seven things
that I post in the gym and the frequency
of it does annoy me sometimes but it
doesn't know me to point to ever say
anything because he is who he is and I
am Who I am
he has every right to say if you if if
it brought me that much I block him yeah
yeah yeah and it doesn't bother me that
much but yeah if that makes his day kind
of thing peace be on to him that's his
problem
yeah I'm fine with that but then it made
me realize I've
message skills family I've harassed like
in the past
are you not now but I've probably slid
in about over a hundred dm's in my
Instagram lifespan yeah I've been aired
probably more than 100 times do you know
I mean do you know I'm coming from Brian
it's like and you're one of many I'm one
of many if I get annoyed from one guy
every every one three weeks
girls get hollered every single day by a
hundreds of guys wrong firm and long
girls it's long
brav exactly that little bit escalated
there's a guy so when I used to work
with Lois mmm David Lloyd yeah one of
the members there he's like no nor among
the stark as he'd like he just basically
lives at the club firm like good pays
for PT pays for all sorts and he's there
all the time here and he's gay his name
is bent he's a [ __ ] funny nice guy
but he fancies Lewis he fancies him yeah
and he is not shy about sharing yeah he
will always say like he'll come up to
man and be like ruff I would love to
[ __ ] you like I would love to [ __ ] you
and like Lewis is supposed to take it as
a compliment
exactly what you're saying there guys
say that's a girls all the time and my
man does not take it as a compliment man
he's just like for [ __ ] sake and he
tries to laugh it off yeah but I
remember thinking like and obviously at
the same time it's not as bad for Lewis
because if Lewis want to beat the [ __ ]
out of this guy he could mmm and like so
it's not there's no fear either yeah oh
yeah but when for a woman who is so much
smaller and weaker than a man for a
grown-ass man to come here I'd love to
[ __ ] II like let me [ __ ] you like that
must be [ __ ] Terry I am terrified big
hole man six six at one Wham grabs your
wrist tight like midnight my pulls you
just like [ __ ] [ __ ] do in clubs
grabs the wrist pulls you back and says
I'd love to [ __ ] you how scared would
you be [ __ ] the women go through that
daily day and a daily [ __ ] you're the
river and
appeasement I salute you Monica yeah
these women a strong firm I'm not
dealing but I'm not dealing I did it
that's too much a suicide
I couldn't do that every day every day
that's all day every day all day every
day a lot of people feed off it though
but they do like that my man damn and
they deal with like that's just basic
st. I want to [ __ ] you it's just basic
and obviously my man sending you
wherever he sends you it's just basic
imagine women go through the thing but
remember the moment that slid into our
DMS oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like I want to watch one of us yeah how
much so let me wax you that's disgusting
lot of random as well gusted 1.5 that's
the answer that was 1.5 is Beyonce
stills that this bills there me fam 1.5
k you can mask me
but let me go through that all the time
this weird send me a picture of your fee
let me shave you let me suck your toes
like that's just all the time like I've
spoken she goes before and they're just
like Bravo I can't handle tinder tinder
was dead for me fam no one tried to [ __ ]
with the only person that physically
tried to [ __ ] me was a guy on tinder
like a transsexual yeah man said I'm at
this hotel come true and I didn't even
know it was a guy yeah I was thinking
brah man said I will suck you off
I can't member what he said he said like
something like if you like head
I'm in this hotel fighting fire and
obviously I only saw his little
thumbnail T and I'm like yes I'm
probably not gonna go because I don't
know I might get stabbed
yeah but like hey maybe you never know
maybe a couple tequila's I might be
thinking sighting do yeah and then I
went on the pages I asked a guy it makes
sense okay cool great it's a guy wants
or something off um but yeah tinder I
said so goes like I was thinking what's
so happy about tinder and all it is is
dick pics
guys saying weird [ __ ] they want to do
this they want to do that like send me a
picture of days like I want to piss on
me and we
this is just like make guys are nasty
and you know as mad as well I was
actually talking someone rise every day
like it wasn't about sick [ __ ] like that
but it was about you know when girls or
like girls will tell me like feet our
female friends and stuff will tell me
and I think he was actually I do who was
it was Chloe
mmm-hmm our mutual friend Chloe she I
was on the phone to her a couple months
ago and she was talking about guys right
and then she was like Bob I always get
the crazy guys like they're always like
crazy clingy and I always want this and
they always saying this and they're
always getting like [ __ ] insecure
about what I'm not messaging them back
I'm not doing this I'm not doing that
and I'm like gruff yeah who are these
guys yeah I you every guy you meet seems
to be like this I don't know any man
like this yeah and then I thought maybe
I do I was thank you I bet I do
man I'm all doing it that's so funny and
no one's telling me they're always
putting on a brave face they send me the
screen shows they want to send me yeah
yeah if I'm dead tell me what's really
going on
maybe they dude she was like one
hundreds in they do the hundred on you
and although wow that's funny
that's crazy I'm funny because you're
laughing cuz you know it's true it's
true
not for me not for me but yeah
definitely man are doing then just not
tell you yeah they're just not telling
[ __ ] hell from that when that hit me
resonated yeah mind blown
I was like wow wow up and lied to I've
been lied to by my friends [ __ ] you know
you're funny
brav but yeah man that was Jared
Bravo Jared through it Randy Andy have
you ever have you ever felt like this
completely off stopping I'm like sign
different have you ever felt like you've
been racially profiled like out work or
you know just on like a day to day do
you ever feel like there's been a time
you eat that sticks out that [ __ ]
racially prove out
um we'll just like that typical
stereotype I think for me let me have a
think I I can't think of something
hopefully something will come to me in a
minute but I wouldn't say I have
necessarily well like I said nothing
comes to mind right now but what I will
say that does happen to me in particular
so I've thought about this a lot not
that I've been racially profiled but it
guess it is profiling in a way in that
obviously my dad is black and my mom is
white mm-hmm some every part is black as
much as I am white mm-hmm but white
people know I'm just white people the
majority of the population would just
say I'm black mm-hmm they were never
acknowledged me as white I'm as far as
they're concerned I'm not white
whatsoever and they might call me
mixed-race to be politically correct but
as far as anything else goes I'm black
and that have thats never not happened
mmm only black people would call you mix
red we'll call me mixed-race we kiss
yeah obviously I'm not a full black and
maybe like you man or someone might like
say a little joke or a diggable are
that's the white inside of you or
whatever whatever but yeah as far as
like anyone who's not black calls me
black and that is like it doesn't bother
me because it's just my life and I'm not
ashamed of it but at the same time it's
like why yeah I'm good I'm not like it
I'm being because it's so common
I'm almost being forced to accept the
fact that I'm I'm not allowed to have my
own identity in a way like cuz I'm not
I'm not black and like for me I'm I've
never really button I've rarely ever boy
up to someone you're gonna say oh
because you're black and I kind of just
get on with it yeah and like I said it
doesn't bother me
yeah but at the same time it kind of
does bother me yeah I guess it's like
well I'm not black yeah I'm not black
I'm not white and like when white people
talk to me like they'll talk to me as if
I'm the token black guy yeah Bob like I
just as much white yeah and just as much
white and like when I'm with white
people not saying like I'm I'm not
accepted but like in a racial context
I'm so much more seen like if I'm in a
group of black guys so obviously all you
guys all my closest friends are black um
I'm so much more socially accepted in a
racial manner then when I'm in a group
of white friends so if I'm in a group of
white people yeah it's it's like not a
topic of conversation but it's so like
our James is the black guy in this group
yeah but when I'm in a group of black
people mmm even sometimes there's a joke
you might be like James is the light guy
or the light-skinned guy in this group
um it's not part of the conversation
yeah yeah whereas if I'm in a group of
white people is always part of the
conversation yeah and like that is the
same is if you were in a group like
anyone who's fully black that's exactly
the same but I'm also in that category
as well even though I'm just as much
white as I am black yeah no one who's
white ever ever see that is that they
never EC even if they've met my mum yeah
who is white yeah they don't see that I
am white yeah never ever ever it's never
happened no one white has ever seen me
as white yeah they only see me as black
yeah so I guess that that's pretty much
the only racial profile I've had
okay what about you I'm gonna tell you a
give me an example I don't even know if
it was racial profiling or just flout
fear this was years ago which is so
weird this was years ago I was still at
work and I got on the market at that
time so this is a good five years ago
maybe I was I was walking home from work
so I got off at my station and a chick
caught off at the station I don't you
gotta find a station or we just come in
slightly slide walking down the same
path so she was walking in front of me
and I was walking behind her it was late
so it was it would have been around
after midnight court to one kind of
thing so it's lame I'm walking home
she's walking home in front of me she's
drinking a can I remember I remember
this like it was yesterday because I
thought of the repercussions that could
have put
happened yeah I mean I was walking home
she was white
obviously I'm black she was walking home
I was walking home same direction she
was ahead of me and then all of a sudden
she finished I can she dropped it on the
floor and [ __ ] sprint no fact it was
just me and her oh my god he [ __ ]
sprinted I've never seen anything like
it because he's not like she was jogging
beforehand it's like you miss a bus
she was casually walking with a can of
whatever looked back saw me finishing
dropped it and darted oh my god
absolutely darted out of me so offended
I was one I was extremely offended
purely because big man I am walking the
same way as you because I'm going home I
live this way help me I can't help it
but what made it even worse was the
sonorous that came into my head so let's
say randomly where she was going was
down the road let's say she was going to
be her boyfriend or her dad for [ __ ]
sake no down the road she could have
said this black gates following yes yes
I would have been killed
yeah dude oh hey hey I hate you like
just off the fact that I am walking home
yeah and she assumed I was [ __ ] gonna
try and attack whoever yeah yeah so
she'd so have her fight-or-flight
response was she's gonna [ __ ] fly
she's gonna rough this actually mad as
well because like that's one example
bro okay like real quick bike it's mad
that like what you just said like the
word black you put it in front and
something in carries more weight yeah a
lot more weight and it's not even it
annoys me because it's not even just
that happens to like white people were
Asian people if you tell them that it
cares no way for them it carries more
weight for everyone it kept away from me
yeah like if like if someone's telling a
story and they're like alright so yeah
exactly the same thing like I was
walking down the street and this group
of guys came out of a oh [ __ ]
if someone's like I was walking down the
street and then this group of black guys
came out even I'm life stories are
interesting
the story's a bit more interesting oh I
know I know how [ __ ] yeah it speak
that's what how is we're accustomed to
it now like it's we've fallen into the
same thing the same system it's mad
it's awkward it's horrible but it's true
right if you put black in front it's
scary so much more way he's scary now so
much more way oh yeah six-foot big white
guy
okay okay okay yeah he's big he's
probably plays lacrosse yeah if it's a
six-foot sighing black guy he just got a
pen
obviously he's a criminal obviously with
three baby mums their own life come
incidentally they're all white far broth
is actually Matt he's actually mad and I
trust me I'm laughing about in theory
it's not funny but it's like you have to
laugh about
I've said in previous episode you have
to see the chest and everything nowadays
you did you have to see or else you'll
[ __ ] kill yourself like yeah dude
that sari is [ __ ] funny I'm sorry
that story [ __ ] fan funny she
sprinted hmm and it was just me and her
on right so let's even say a car was
driving past and saw just her running
away from me mm-hmm imagine that car
then pulled up and be like what the [ __ ]
is happening
yeah brav are you okay to the go yeah
you makes up a lie like oh my god I
don't know if I'm safe this guy's good I
mean mm-hmm
I'm a little guy just coming up from
work cuz do you know I mean hey hey
but then guys in America obviously it
happens a lot my own American does here
this is the reason why they're [ __ ]
angry all the time that's why black
people are angry dude we're not angry
because well you're for a reason
profile yeah but to be that way 1%
hundred percent it's crazy because
obviously black guys see as that as well
because like you said if you say black
in front of everything it carries a lot
more weight but that's because this
that's what the system is embedded in us
yeah [ __ ] wild to East another
example this is not my example but it's
just racial profiling as a standard yes
there was an interview with Lupita the
actress so it was two white presenters
and Lupita and there were songs are
about another random
v that's someone else starting it was
another Africa I think repeat our camera
with the pizzas for him I think it's
she's from South Africa correct me if
I'm wrong apologize if I am wrong I
remember where she's from but she's from
a country and I've got karma where she's
from and then they said someone else is
named as an actress that's from a
completely different country and then
presented us Lapita oh that I saved that
name right and then the PTO's like I
have no idea but she said it in a
politically in a political way that was
correct because she was on live TV yeah
if I was repeat I'll be so [ __ ] at
you how do you think I wouldn't know how
to say a name purely because I'm black
Rob do you know what I mean yeah do I
expect you to know some Norwegian name
like just because you're nice in Hans
you know 300 said did you know so if
anyone's seen that little sketch I think
it's are on Twitter if anyone's seen
that that just resonated with me just
because it's it's just a standard
profile straight away because she's
black because she's African she must
automatically understand where
everyone's names wrong or if they've
said it right and blah blah blah
to be fair more time she may have known
but just right you know the funny thing
is about that mmm dread ie there's a
girl that I work with I think she's left
now hmm but um she is from Ghana mm-hmm
I do that to her on purpose I racial
profile so many stories that she tells
me and she gets so angry but I'm always
right and I'm not proud of it but it
pisses her off so much I can't help
myself so like there's one time he's got
a baby water what she hates Angie wonder
she hates me like they just she'll be
telling a story and she'll be like oh
yeah cuz I laughed loud obviously yeah
when I laugh like it's the whole office
shuts down if something hits me in my
sternum like the whole office shuts yeah
so she'll say like change what laugh is
so extra like yeah you brand me of my
friend like like I used to work with
discussions to refresh his team says my
friend she was like you my name is guy
used to work with like literally every
time she laughed she will fall on the
floor and I should do this I love she
black in it she was like why did you say
that I was like because she's like why
would you [ __ ] say that why would you
you
she's like you you black yourself why
don't you jump to that conclusion and
I'll let carry on and carry on and carry
her and I'm like but she was black any
sir yes she's back cuz black people do
that extra was so extra and then there's
another time there's another time there
was uh there was another time there was
literally exactly what you just said
there was a name there was a name an
African name and I couldn't pronounce it
and I said her I said it to wind her up
and I was like I said the name
incorrectly so no no no no I could ID
couldn't pronounce okay so I said to her
someone said to me James how do you
pronounce his name so basically there
was a client that needs to be caught
okay had like a really like an African
name mmm they could pronounce it and
then not because I'm black just because
they were sit next to me this it gives
you now to pronounce this and then
because I knew it would wind her up I
was like her name is Frida ask freedom
and then she was like why would you tell
them to ask me yeah and then I was like
I just feel like you'd know she ready
and she was like first of all I'm from
Ghana
that's a Nigerian name and I was like I
don't know what name that is you I you
just taught me as a Nigerian which means
you probably know how to pronounce it so
let's just get the song starts over with
and tell us what the name is hope she
hates me so much and like I hate the
Rochelle racial profile of a little set
from you have to laugh yeah you just got
Yahtzee digest in there you have to firm
and it's just [ __ ] ridiculous that
reminds me when you said when I was
saying earlier about on the people
profiling me as black yeah even though
I'm not there's been two times in my
life mmm which it was weird it was a
weird situation cuz I didn't really know
how it was like a conflict of my kind of
inner emotions yeah we can't deal with
it for a little bit that like I can't
think of a better way to explain it but
almost made me resent my blackness
mm-hmm
in the way that not that I wanted to be
white mm-hmm in a way that I wanted to
have like my own sense of identity so
much mhm that made me wish I wasn't
black so when I was a kid the first time
happened when I was a kid that was a
girl I was in primary school and you
know when you're in primary school you
haven't even a PP yet you're not
thinking about section or thinking
anything yeah but like when you fancy a
girl when you think you fancy ago you're
in love with yeah of course but there
was one girl called crystal mmm right so
Michael I was in whites oh my god
I was infatuated with her yeah in light
year six yeah and I firm I loved her
like I literally loved her and there was
one time my boy was having a fireworks
party yeah and he invited me over and
literally I went over there and it's her
her friend who happened to be related to
my boy so that's why they were there
my heart's beating mmm I don't know oh
[ __ ] and then my boy his name was Scott
I remember he was like crystals here and
I was like fat I know I know I know
she's here Cena and then um before you
finish the story I'm so sweet because I
feel like this is a story that you tell
me what sweater yeah yeah yeah I was
like 10
I know crystals here obviously it's
poppin' I was ready to move to it but I
was wrong this fam so funny times I'm 20
I still consoles ago so these time I in
year six I was petrified like my skin
was cold and I was like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is my chance but you have to make
her my girlfriend yeah but there's no
dating when you're in a state yeah even
my girlfriend or you're not you were
getting married under the tree or we're
not you have your job and lunch with me
or with nothing yeah um so literally I
said to my boy but if you're gonna have
to do this thing for me you're gonna
have the chapter crystal yes tell her I
like her she lays the information or
relays the informations to your cousin
and it comes back to me through a third
channel and we're gonna make this thing
work
yeah fam rode up and thing is to this
day I don't know if what she said
is true mm I hope for [ __ ] sake is not
true yeah but Scott rolls over to her
mmm and says James likes you do you like
James what you saying what you say and
man comes back to me fam I'm twiddling
thumbs
he was like brother you're not going to
like what she said and I was like oh
here we go oh my god
I'm hideous I know I am this is when I
haven't grown into my teeth yeah you
know when you lose your teeth when your
t four massive when they grow back as we
gonna see I had the biggest back to you
bro I was like it's mighty it's it's
mighty that's the V mother you haven't
grown into my teeth and she's not feelin
me and then um she said her dad said she
she's not allowed to date black guys
these times I think back yeah and I
think we're in you see yes six your dad
did not say don't date black guys your
Ted
what kind of Nazi dad do you have that
he's in stood in this mentality to you
when you're ten years old at the time I
was Harbor come here I was so young that
I didn't even think your dad's a prick
like I was just like fair enough but
these times I'm like I'm not black yeah
like granted you can't date black guys
sucks for their beer I'm not black you
might if I said I liked her she'd
written you off she would've scream to
affirm the thing is as well like now I
figured about it probably wasn't true
maybe she just didn't like black guys
and stuff like that but the time like it
was so annoying that like she couldn't
even give me the time of day to say like
I don't date mixed-race guys like like
even I don't even like guys of color
like anyone that's not white I don't
like I would have preferred that at that
time too I don't date black guys yeah
cuz it's like you've lumped me into a
thing that's not even you who I am yeah
like and I'm proud to be black but like
I'm not yeah like I'm not black and
you've just you just said I don't like
black guys and it's like it's literally
at the time she could have said to me I
don't date indian guys mmm cuz I was
just like okay are we doing this or not
thanks for the irrelevant races
information
I'll be date you know and like brother
was mad and that was the first time that
happened to me and in a second time if
we say ii was mad is that she's probably
[ __ ] black guys now of course
everyone is bro all of them are um
anyway yeah funny you should say that
because I actually saw her a year or two
ago and in past in Mike she came this is
when I was working for David Lloyd she
came in my boy Lewis actually signed her
and I saw her name on like a contract in
my office and I was like how do i last
name was no but I saw her name and I was
like [ __ ] that's that's the year six go
yeah I don't [ __ ] black guys yeah um I
was like can't be the same guy mmm this
is a different city this is different
I'm this when I lived in Luton and I was
working like in Milton Keynes now so
obviously not that far apart but like I
was a cop it's anger and then I saw her
come in to like sign a contract in [ __ ]
and I was like and I was like so
embarrassed that I wanted to I literally
wanted her to say like do you remember
she would've been like hell no hmm when
we were in year six were at Scott's
[ __ ] fire rat spy I was in love with
you you told me you don't like black
guys was it true what is [ __ ] in 18
years later and I'm still burning but
the second time wasn't even long ago hmm
in that there was a girl that was
talking to and she said to me like oh
she likes me whatever and when weapon
and she doesn't understand I tried to
explain it to her but she wasn't
understanding that what she was saying
was really really hurt me and offended
me hmm in that like she was trying to
pay me a compliment and she was
basically saying like oh you don't get
it I'm like really not attracted to
black guys but I am attracted to you I
hate [ __ ] like that and I'm like okay
and then she was like no really like
I've never fancied a black guy but like
I really fancy I'm like stop saying that
yeah and then like she was like what I'm
like I'm just letting you know like
obviously this is like it is a teen for
me that is a big deal for me
like it shouldn't be a [ __ ] big deal
for you and like secondly I'm not black
yeah like stop profiling me felt like
I'm my own race on my own person like
I'm just like what is this whole like
you're not doing me a favor by fancying
me yeah like I shouldn't be grateful to
you that you find me attractive because
I'm a subsection of the race that you
deem unattractive yeah like bro that
like mind-boggling man it was even more
mind-boggling the fact that she thought
she was paying me a compliment she
genuinely thought she was doing me a
favor
and that she thought I should be happy
like rah she doesn't face it guys but
she messes me like I must be buff yeah
like you hurt my feelings well yeah
you're profiling me if you won and
you're degrading my heritage for two and
it's just like what is happening what is
that what's the point is go brother
it's mad in this day and age in this day
and age man I talking about I don't date
black guys but lucky you you're alright
you're one of the good ones must be the
white in you famiiy was he was mad I see
no question
brav I'm happy you asked me that
question cuz I didn't think it was gonna
get that much out of me Breivik crystal
fire 18 years ago my dad said my dad
said it might you know what speakers
well you know I was actually [ __ ] peak
me you know why she's lucky that I'm a
shy guy hmm imagine if I'd went to my
dad and said uh imagine because me and
my dad don't talk like that
but ideally I would like to have a ratio
up of my kids in which they can just
tell me anything yeah I didn't have that
relationship my dad so lucky for her I
didn't go back to my dad mmm like come
over he dropped me off and pick me up so
imagine if he picked me up and was like
oh how was the team how's the fireworks
and I was like yeah I was all right I
told this girl that I like a school that
I like her and if she wants go out me
and she told me that she can't because
her dad said she's not another date bad
guys my dad would have killed something
he would have peel back into that yard
he would appeal back and be like what
mmm and he would have got the dad down
there
and imagine if the dad never said that
yeah imagine if she made that whole
thing up is the hunt all over again
literally is the who's to blame yeah
because the dad must be thinking where
did you get that funny
this black guy's gonna kill me I
wouldn't do it sir man that's funny I
was genuine fear I was scared would you
be I didn't say that and then no one's
believing him say it you mean literally
bastard you've not seen you you said it
like stop lying you [ __ ] said it it
me you said it I'm Azhar figma I never
[ __ ] said that I swear to God I don't
know where she got out that's anyone I
don't [ __ ] believe you
I believe this vulnerable ten-year-old
girl from and then like my mom must be
thinking if he made it out of there
unscathed he would literally be thinking
where did that come from I did she get
that from and why did you say that yeah
because why don't you wanted a black guy
yes that's crazy
mmm at ten years old ten fun ten she's
dropping bars
I don't date black guys date you look
bad now if I remember fam you know a
speak as well because I remember the day
before I'm [ __ ] lucky because the day
before I was gonna send her one of those
notes do you like me yes no maybe I was
gonna send her that I would round this
thing I would have got back there Blake
black guys I would have sent that to
miss straightaway head office head
office straightaway fab it's actually
peak because like I've got all these
unsolved mysteries in my life because I
was such a shy kid yeah and like stuff
like experiences like that like made me
so much more shy like I I always look
back and think of my life like I've
never really experienced any racism or
everything's been blessed but then
little snippets like you just have to
ask me the right the right question yeah
and I'm like oh [ __ ] that was racist
yeah like that was [ __ ] racism Jesus
I was only 10
no one [ __ ] up but it's crazy it was
crazy
yeah man this whole race game is a dance
felt hard like we I didn't ask it
because I wanted to express something I
asked it just because I wanted to get
another person's point of view you know
I mean obviously you've been best friend
it's good to hear other people's
opinions and whatever about the
situation with me it's like I always
feel like regardless of wherever I am in
my career anything I'm always gonna be
judged or watched em because I'm a black
guy and I don't I don't mean that in
like a drug-free way because I feel like
I don't people to pity me or whatever I
just feel like I've always got to be on
edge well I'm always got be extra nice
because I'm gonna be deemed as are the
reason why sighs in this place because
it's black yeah you know I know I know
and I've obviously people don't know my
voice I see all my other career and I've
tamed myself to be or act a specific way
because I've learned how to control my
patience hmm and that's because I work
in Australia you have that patience to
work in Australia but there are
distinctive moments where I feel like
it's jarring because people only people
think one thing where they know nothing
about me so for example we had a private
room a private hire rather and the
guests were being a bit noisy and
redditor doing like handstands Jen I
taught him to slab I saw on camera that
I walked in and I told him to stop and
then immediately they thought with the
doorman
immediately yeah immediately like yeah
and you know what's worse one of the
other managers was in the room wearing
exactly the same jacket I was worried
because we will have different jackets
for different like for hierarchy but
because of my skin color she immediately
thought I was a doorman yeah yeah and
it's like big man I am wearing the same
jacket she's wearing she yeah but I was
just thinking that you know yeah yeah I
need you just have to hold your tongue
and just smile for it so many times but
it's mad because I never ever I'd never
ever will
express this to obviously it's this is
[ __ ] over life so it's pointless now
they say no but in hindsight I would
never ever express this to anyone at
work because people would think people
never get it because they're white yeah
yeah yeah and I know that sounds like
racial profiling but like it would never
get racially profiled yeah exactly
and that's a fact yeah that's a [ __ ]
exactly exactly exactly like there's
certain people don't like there's only
certain minorities that will understand
little nuances that you're saying
exactly the perfect example was like I
was talking to someone the other day and
they'll talk to me about their night out
and they're like oh yeah it was good it
was good it was good like my friend was
being an idiot like um she we were
walking home and there was a dwarf
welcome behind us mmm and he was at one
of the DJ's at the club so my friend
stopped and spoke to him and I
immediately knew that he knew that the
only reason she stopped and spoke to him
cause he's a dwarf and if he was a
random guy walking home from the club
just like I'm sure there were 20 other
random guys on the street walking home
from the club she wouldn't spoke to them
and like the girl told me likely didn't
see any issue with like her stopping and
speaking to the guy but I'm like do you
think he wants to be stopped and spoke
to because he's not need to you he knows
you were only doing it because he's a
dwarf like you might think you're being
nice but you're really not you're not
and you're profiling this guy and you're
like segregating this guy you might
think you're doing him a favor but you
actually segregate and and he can't even
walk home in peace because it's almost
like a sideshow side act and that's what
it's not really similar but exactly what
you were saying about in terms of like
you feel like you need to make sure
you're in a certain type of way yeah
because of your skin color is also like
with today's culture is it's it's like
people are it's not so prevalent in this
country yeah in America it definitely is
in terms of like the need for diversity
and equality
stuff like that yeah like I might people
might disagree with me whole hardly on
this but like I am so against in this
day and age I feel like there was
definitely a time for it
there was a time for it where racial
minorities were separated and it was
difficult for someone who was black who
was Asian whatever to get in a certain
place in business
it was difficult yeah I don't live in
America but it's not as difficult as it
was mmm like if you're qualified you can
get a job [ __ ] what you say like we do
live in a time people don't want to
accept it but we do live in a time in
which you can achieve what you want to
achieve regardless of what your skin
color is we do you just need to believe
it and there might there yes there are
always going to be exceptions I'm always
gonna be exceptions there are gonna be
[ __ ] here and [ __ ] there but
wholeheartedly I can say with confidence
from my own experience from looking at
your experience for looking at my
friends experience that you someone
looking at my dad's experiences are that
someone who has he was powerful racial
minority can achieve something in
business yeah off their own merit so the
the the push that you see and you read
her stuff about like for diversity and
equality and stuff like that stuff like
that annoys me because like just what
you said like I don't want people to
seem in a certain way and assume I'm
like this because I'm black and I also
wouldn't want to be in a situation where
people look at me and think I'm only
here because I'm black like I didn't get
here by myself like yeah we needed the
black guy there's not enough black guys
in here like we need the black guy and
like so balance out and like is stuff
like that is like I think is such a
controversial opinion to have but
sometimes the more attention you make of
it the bigger deal you make out of it
you actually sometimes do more harm than
good yeah of course like private sample
like I had a girl a woman she's she's
only got the best intention she's only
got the best intentions and and she's an
African lady and she wanted to set up a
situation where
people from the office could go to a go
to some kind of organization or charity
or something like that and speak to a
few people who are less privileged and
they're struggling with work and they're
they a lot of my younger people and they
don't have very many role models and
stuff like that and they're trying to
achieve something that she's trying to
show this is what can be achieved yeah
and then she sent an email round but she
only sent it to the ethnic minorities in
the office said oh do you want to come
down this this and I saw the names that
obviously were an email and I was like
and then she sent a follow-up email said
are in case you're wondering why I've
only sent it to the ethnic minorities in
the offices because a lot of the people
at this place are part of ethnic
minorities and I think it would be good
for them to see people of their own
color like doing work and I'm like I
understand you only have the best
intentions but I don't want to be
singled out like that yeah like I'm here
the same way she's here I'm here the
same way he's here I'm there
regardless of our race and I'm I'm not
something to be celebrated yeah because
I am this color and I am where I am in
business that like I understand that you
only have the best intentions yeah but
there is also other perspect don't want
to be celebrated I don't want to be
singled out I don't want to be the guy
that's like oh we need diversity we need
to show what someone who looks like
James can achieve look what James is
like no leave me alone because I did it
the same way Sharon did it like I don't
want to be singled out like that I
haven't done anything like or done
anything out of it I haven't done
anything out of the ordinary yeah I've
done the same thing as everyone else so
why should I be made to feel like oh
you're lucky or you've done well like
stuff like that like wait why why should
I be made to feel like that just like
that's even though you're trying to be
positive yeah you're profiling me just
the same way like someone who's trying
to be negative for it and it doesn't
make me feel any better
yeah but I immediately
Pilon was like I ain't goin no where ya
goin no no I'm staying here Brock was
talking about jobs and stuff deputy
Murray has worn off so I was talking to
one of the door this is another
completely separate occasion I was
talking to one of the doormen at work
Quinn scenario obviously he's black and
we're just randomly talking around me
talking I don't think about there
anymore now actually and then he asked
me how long have I been here in where I
was like six months or so and it was
like oh how'd you get to be a manager so
quick
and I'm thinking what do you even mean
yeah what do you actually even mean but
or do you actually mean by that yeah
yeah I was like bro I being a manager do
you not I mean yeah and I feel like I
know for a fact he wouldn't have asked
that question if I was white yeah
do you know I mean I feel like it made
me upset thinking that he feels being a
black managers a privilege yeah exactly
you know I mean and whereas his job is a
bit more degrading he's putting himself
he's capping his own limitations 100% it
just but I did say any of that to him
place
it was my immediate thought yeah I'm
thinking why would you even ask me that
hmm because I know for I know where
you're going with that question hmm
but you don't want to say the specifics
yeah yeah I've only been here for six
I've been a manager for years yes that's
how I got the job
yeah yeah exactly what kind of question
is that my CV firm that's how I'm a
manager barians a bid man yeah I'm just
I'm like it's nothing to do with like
rod they must be looking for more black
managers it was it was weird to me bro
weird to me but yeah I'm so happy I
don't know why I'm happy to ask that
question but it's not it's not even like
it was on my chest actually the reason
why I did was because I think I maybe I
experienced something I played it down I
was like we have to talk about that girl
stories [ __ ] funny [ __ ] oh honey
drank her drink drops it on the floor
and darted she's salutely sprin she must
have been so terrified I wonder if she
got home before why did I do that or for
thankthank bar yes I had the wrong
it's either R or cuz there's no in
between there is no in between hundred
percent hundred percent there's no in
between but the fear the fear of
the field gnome in that potentially she
could have told someone or maybe this
guy's following me and then there a
bottle from that who would who would who
would believe me
yeah yeah yeah and it's like the thing
is as well it's not even that a case
that we're saying if it was any white
guy they wouldn't have done it mmm but
it's a case of saying in order to put
fear in her like that you would assume
that the the the the guy that she's
looked back and seen would have had to
have some form of shady charisma about
them so like it could have been a drug
addict or a homeless person or like any
character risky or there could have been
like white guy were [ __ ] tattoos on
his head or look like you just got out
of prison like you've got to have
certain characteristics in that scenario
if you are white I was saying if you
were white you might have to have
certain characteristics to fit that
profile to give someone enough fear to
[ __ ] sprint via like obviously we
could be completely wrong yeah and she
could be a hypochondriac yeah and she'll
sprint from anyone it could be the
chicken she could have run but the
chances are the fact that you were black
you even though you were probably
wearing a suit hmm it gave her more
excuse to run then if it was a white on
a suit or a young Chinese guy in a suit
no one's running from a Chinese guy huh
you see Chinese guy Dan walking down a
road you're calm you're fine hey which
way do in che black guys teef in you he
just is it's eating you or raping you
one of the two it's crazy mum it is
crazy and just like we said it's crazy
that we subconsciously even though we
would moan about we subconsciously
subscribe to it of course of course
because it's part of the nature day and
day out like you can't stop yourself
from thinking certain things it just
autonomously happens it does
autonomously happen and the thing is as
well this sucks to say it's not it's
stupid for me to say because I'm never
gonna wrap up in a minute
mmm but it's not unsubstantiated as well
it's not we're not even though were
saying like always the system has led
you to believe it's not just that from
experience alone yeah like I was saying
I was actually
the other week too when we're on the way
here mmm like yes people like you say
are like you see group black guys and
people are more afraid than they should
be because of this and that I was like
that's true mmm but us as a collective
we're all black guys if we go to if we
take a reading of our anxiety levels or
our adrenaline levels if I went into a
white rave or if I went into a black
rave spike in a little brother because
you know from his very area there's
probably going to be a fight potential
yeah somebody can get linked and that's
not the system lamb it's just experience
that's just the monkeys wanna fight
these [ __ ] these goddamn [ __ ]
can't stop fighting man these
cotton-pickin sugar canes tripping
[ __ ] this just experiences guys want
to scrap it's true Bob it's mad it is
mad but um yeah if I'm nice wrap this up
that was a good one
it's [ __ ] long the grabs it allows
long